getting over
covet 19 baby i finally got it
were you did you eat a pangolin
i
i don't know how i got it but i just um
it was probably just because every
everybody i know has it everyone in la
has it
it's this you're vaccinated so it's it's
you know it's helping you
i mean you know what's so funny is no
you could tell that no one has any trust
in the vaccine because as soon as you
tell people you have it they're like oh
my god
oh my god and i'm like well i'm
vaccinated i'm supposed to be okay right
you're like dude be careful literally
people were texting me like be care i'm
like
and these are the same people they were
like you got to get faxed
as soon as you get it they're like how
long do you have yeah they're like it's
my aunt's texting me she's like it's
scary it's very scary i'm like i thought
the whole idea was that you got the
vaccine so that you you wouldn't you
wouldn't be inundated with texts like
are your affairs in order
no one wants
people are addicted to
the death drama now yes no one we can't
go back we're not gonna go back to like
you know occasionally someone dies and
we're fine we just live our lives if
people don't have a death every day to
talk about or someone dying or someone
in the hospital they're going to lose
their minds it gives their lives meaning
yeah it gives real life culture now yeah
it's a death culture it's a good point
and what's interesting about
um having this is it is you know
worrisome you know you try to stay off
the internet when you have it right
because there's always like a case
there'll always be something to read
about
where you go oh [ __ ] you know right
um some there's always someone who's
died of everything like everything out
there you could die of someone has right
and what's interesting about kovan now
is people act like it's the only thing
killing people in america right like
it's the only thing this is a country
okay that has mass shootings an insanely
high homicide rate an opioid crisis
school shootings all the time
uh insane rates of cancer heart disease
all kinds of problems um suicide ptsd
untreated mental illness horrible roads
traffic accident but people act like
covet is just the only danger out there
cops are fighting hookers with like
their throats caught going look over
it's getting nasty
which fear which variant is this yeah
which variant is this where i shoot an
innocent black guy in a 7-eleven parking
lot
what varian is that i don't know
um
you know i went so i went i got this
monoclonal antibody infusion which
really helps it's the same thing they
gave to trump
and uh you know being bigger now i'm
gonna try to really lose weight now
because this is not going anywhere
covered clearly and it's just gonna
survive covered why lose the weight
well i just think it's still it's a
better idea i got to prepare for
whatever the next variant is going to be
sure
the next variant's going to be like this
it's going to be hilarious you're going
to be like
not only does the vaccine not help the
next variant it hurts
they're gonna be like are you vaccinated
well then the next variant's gonna [ __ ]
you up watch the [ __ ] out
right
so uh i i went and i got this monoclonal
antibody infusion it's made by a company
called regeneron
which is um
the thing that trump got now i don't
know why it's not widely available it is
kind of like a miracle
drug i feel much better in in under 48
hours really i felt better in 24 hours i
mean it's hard to mass produce when
you're based out of uh argentina using
old nazi science right
well
well what's good about texas is all the
doctors here are queuing on so they'll
literally
they'll do anything right
like when i went in the doctor's like
did you get vac i was like yeah he was
like all right like he wasn't like good
for you or he goes ah all right
and then he goes like this he goes you
want survivor mectin
and i went well i don't know
and he goes how about this he calls me
up he goes why don't you go to a website
it's going to tell you all about the
ivermectin
he didn't even say like he didn't say
what iver mech thing is he's just like
he's
watch the trailer yeah
he's like have you seen zeitgeist
[Laughter]
uh no he he goes he calls me goes how
are you doing after the antibodies i
said good
uh he goes okay because you want some
ivermectin and i went well i don't
really know i'm like
i don't know that i need it i feel
better he goes listen just go to this
website and it'll tell you all about it
he goes these doctors he goes they're
highly
peer-reviewed he goes they're well
published he goes they're well known and
he goes so i go to the website and and
i'm not saying anything about ivermectin
i'm sure it has success and the people
that believe it or whatever but like
brett weinstein is being interviewed on
this website
bray weinstein's not a doctor though
he's not a doctor he's not he's perhaps
a doctor of something but whatever he's
like not a doctor so it's very
interesting
like
what
i'm looking at youtube link it's
i if you want to take ivermecting link
in bio
yeah no it's it's literally a [ __ ] i
forget what it's called it's called it's
like the covid coalition or something oh
i wish i had the name of it right and
it's like the um
let me try to find it
and uh it's a website where they just
have all these different
is garyvee on there
okay it's called covidcriticalcare.com
flccc alliance frontline coven 19
critical care alliance
we thank you for your continued support
this is going to remind me of the
mortgage crisis so if you go to this it
just is like a bunch of
interviews with people and one of them
is
dr pierre corey and paul marrick discuss
the suppression of good science and more
with brett weinstein
dr corey on how ivermectin defeats the
variants blah blah blah so
it's just so funny i was like okay i've
never been told by a doctor before to go
to a website you know why though is
because when the trial happens and it's
like and so you advise mr dylan to take
ivermectin no you're no uh actually to
clarify i didn't send him to a website
he made his own decisions
he says no there's no doctor advice
going
it's like he's selling you a speed ball
yeah the doctor calls me because listen
uh we've had a lot of success with a new
drug have you heard of the compound
media network
i want you to log on to compound media
and uh i mean listen maybe it works i
don't know but i mean i i feel better my
oxygen levels are good i walk walking
two or three miles a day
um
did you take the effortmectin no i have
a script for it i picked it up i was
like hey if i if i felt bad i was gonna
take it right it's like seven pills a
day or something
that's that's a lot of pills it's a lot
of pills um but i made it through but
you you've never had this as far as you
know
kovid no i'm i'm uh i'm a very healthy
man and i've managed to keep it uh keep
it up at bay
with my uh physical acumen
well and you don't leave your home
i leave occasionally i mean i go out to
dinner i go to the movies
i've seen four or five movies since they
reopened how 1950s of you like i go to
the dinner i go to the movies
you know no but i yeah i'll walk around
and yeah my girlfriend lucy she walks
you know she leaves the house a lot so
you know if she caught it i would get it
so you know i mean it's uh i think it's
not it's not tearing through new york at
the moment but yeah i'm sure it will
at some point yeah again
the doctor calls me back and he goes i
want you to watch a documentary
sit down
you just sit down you know that jesus
that jesus is actually based on the
sumerian myth
anyway take this pill
do you know
that jesus was based on horus
do you know that oh interesting that's
very interesting i'm like can you take
my blood pressure because sit down sit
down and relax for a little bit okay
you know our money is not backed by gold
did you know that
it's backed by nothing
you understand
it's like hey what's what what are my uh
what are my platelets uh
look like oh uh you know debt is slavery
[Laughter]
i'm a bitcoin maximalist
you know it's the only way to keep the
government in check i'm like i
understand is my oxygen good is it above
95 how what what's the thermite paint
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's also some of these doctors in texas
you go where did you go to school like
cause some of them go to like texas
christian academy of jesus you know
well the weird thing is like don't a lot
of them go over like i know like when
people come from other countries they
like
can't their medical license can't
transfer for some reason but like on a
lot of those guys they go down to like
south america to get their licenses a
lot of the times
isn't there a thing that they go to
brazil where they go they're like is
that true i didn't know that i don't
know or like or like some k i think
there's like i think there's like med
schools in the cayman islands that like
some of these guys go to
oh my god
next to the banks that like you know for
all the money
i mean listen i'm happy though i got the
antibody infusion like i am glad that
they were like let's throw everything at
it
yeah no one's taking chances with you no
one no one thinks you're fighting it off
on your own
that's not true i'm white
this is disproportionately affecting
people that are non-white because they
don't get the uh
the blood of the children injected into
them like you did well i was given it
because it's given it there is a group
in texas called
the society for the preservation of
white men
and
and that's who that's literal i'm not
even kidding that's who gave me the the
infusion that's who paid for it
what
it that's who paid for the infusion
i swear to you
what why
it's it's about preserving european
heritage
um
[Music]
that sounds sketchy
is it
a little bit
i'm not sure
[Music]
that's the reason i was able to get this
it said to preserve the the lineage of
europeans
i mean is are you really what they want
to preserve
is what this is i don't i don't ask you
know
i don't ask um